[Music]
a powerful threat has resurfaced I sense
that this force has been waiting
rebuilding its strength and secret until
now
are you guys the new recruits
you fail to see the big picture no
turning back
[Music]
[Music]
dr. strange sent us we're your backup
wizard glow circle right into the middle
of our date
Scott popcorn on the couch and reruns of
Golden Girls is not a date
stop calling it a date how's it going
everybody it's Warren and we have a new
story trailer for Avengers damage
control which is a virtual reality game
that is coming out in eight days now
I've been getting a ton of questions
about this game so I decided to do a
video and hopefully I can answer
everybody's questions in this video so
for starters this is a VR game this has
nothing to do with any movie or TV show
or anything like that coming out I do
find it very ironic though because in
this virtual reality game you are
wearing an Iron Man suit that is made
out of vibranium and the biggest video
I've ever done which is my biggest
theory was that in Avengers and game
Tony Stark would have a vibranium Iron
Man suit which never happened but now
it's happening in a VR game little irony
there but what you need to know about
damage control 1 is it comes out on
October 18th so that's just 8 days away
and as we found out from this trailer
Ultron is making a return as the villain
and it is an Avengers game so it's going
to involve the most recent Avengers not
all of them but in this trailer we can
spot Doctor Strange spider-man the Hulk
war machine ant-man and the wasp Falcon
and a black panther and I'm sure there's
going to be more sadly there is no
sightings of Iron Man or Captain America
but essentially you will be a part of
the Avengers team and you will be
wearing Ironman armor so if you can go
to this virtual reality experience you
can get a tiny taste of what it feels
like to be Ironman so if you can go I
highly recommend that you do go but
unfortunately you can only play it at a
place called the void if you go to
google and you type in the void virtual
reality experience you can find the
closest one to you but unfortunately
there aren't that many in the world
unfortunately right now there are only
about 10 in the United States 3 in
Canada one in Malaysia and one in the
United Arab Emirates
so the VR game isn't exactly too
accessible for the majority of us but
anything new that comes out about it
that gives us more information I will
definitely cover it so we can all know
as
we can but if you do have one near you
and you are planning to go let me know
in the comments down below and if you're
like me and you don't have one near you
you can let out all of your frustration
in the comments below as well don't
forget to subscribe comment and like the
video so you can enter my giveaway for a
chance to win an Xbox one or a ps4 you
can also follow me on Twitter and
Instagram I do random giveaways on there
as well as always thank you all so much
for watching
woof woof